well the most shocking thing about the
Grammy Awards last night was that
apparently they're still doing the
Grammy Awards the second most shocking
thing is that from what I read this
morning they gave the song of the year
honor to Bonnie Raitt who's a talented
and Soulful musical artist who actually
deserves the recognition she was able to
go up to the stage by herself to accept
the award because she wrote and
performed the song herself compare that
to say Beyonce who needs 97 songwriters
and 3 000 producers to manufacture her
music through an assembly line like
process but Bonnie Raitt is not the
person we're supposed to be celebrating
today our adulation is supposed to be
focused primarily on the singers Kim
Petras and Sam Smith they're both white
males but their win is the in the best
pop Duo category supposed to be a
victory for diversity and inclusion as
these are white males who self-identify
as something other than white males Sam
Smith claims to be non-binary while Kim
Petras identifies as a transgender woman
quote unquote here is a Petras accepting
the award and congratulating himself for
his historic achievement listen
Sam graciously wanted me to accept this
award because I'm the first transgender
woman to win this award
s
thank you
um and I just want to thank
um all the incredible transgender
Legends before me who kicked these doors
open for me so I could be here tonight
while he's not the first male to win the
award he's probably not the first male
who dresses like a woman to win it but
he is the first male winner who claims
to be a woman and this is supposed to be
a historic achievement but here's a
perhaps more interesting point about Kim
Petras born Tim Petrus he got gender
reassignment quote-unquote surgery at
the age of 16. in fact back in 2009 the
then aspiring pop star did a media tour
where he was celebrated for Having the
courage to live as his true self with
the aid of you know genital mutilation
and drugs and all the rest of it here's
a clip from an interview on a British
talk show back then listen
but it's not just the scale of her
ambition that makes young Kim very
extraordinary well Kim was born Tim and
is believed to be the youngest person in
the world to have had a sex change and
she joins us now and it's lovely to have
you here thank you thank you very much
indeed so
um so you're born in 1992 in Cologne in
Germany right and we've we've met a
number of of people who've been in a
sort of similar position who've sat
where you're sitting and all have said
from the word go there was no question
that they knew precisely what they were
they were trapped in the wrong body
that's right um I always knew it you
know when I was a little kid I was
always wanting pink dresses Barbie
everything
well there you have it you like pink
dresses you like Barbie
clearly proof that he was born in the
wrong body whatever the hell that's
supposed to mean exactly but his doctors
couldn't give him a new body because
such a thing is impossible you can't
have a new body you only have the body
that you're born with all they could do
is
mutilate the one and the only body that
he has or will ever have and that's what
they did at the age of 16. now keep this
in mind when the left claims that these
procedures aren't being performed on
minors one of the biggest now Grammy
award-winning pop stars in the country
is a male who had his gender reassigned
or confirmed according to the updated
euphemisms as a minor and this was back
in 2009 when the medical guidelines were
stricter than they are today though
obviously they were not nearly strict
enough even then now the song that won
the award is aptly titled Unholy and the
two award-winning males performed it for
the assembled audience after they won
this award Madonna who uh with each
passing day comes to more and more
resemble the creepy puppet from the the
saw franchise introduced The Duo who
then launched into a blatantly demonic
performance
the whole thing was designed to look
like some kind of satanic sex ritual
with fire and devil horns and BDSM
themes and Sam Smith dressed like Satan
here's a clip and make sure you pay
attention all the way to the end of this
clip watch
[Music]
[Applause]
the Satanic ritual brought to you by
Pfizer a little too on the nose I have
to say
now needless to say the main reason they
went all in with the campy Party City
devil costumes and demonic imagery and
all of that is that they want attention
Sam Smith is the same guy who just
released a music video that shows him
parading around at a piss orgy drinking
urine he's uh desperate to be noticed
and will do literally whatever it takes
he certainly can't rely on the quality
of his music to speak for itself I mean
putting aside The Satanist stuff just
listen to the lyrics from that Unholy
song that we just heard a clip of
lyrics mommy don't know Daddy's getting
hot at The Body Shop doing something
Unholy he sat back while she's dropping
it she'd be popping it yeah she put it
down slowly
this is just absolute brain rotting
stupidity these are alleged artists who
have no art to offer nothing to say no
Talent no creativity
and so they can only try to shock us
there's always been art with immoral
messages the difference is that in
modern times our immoral art is produced
by the most tiresome collection of
monotonous talentless idiot hacks to
ever walk the earth
as I said about Sam Smith's pea guzzling
music video this stuff is indeed
offensive and gross and disgusting Etc
it's all of that
but it's also utterly tedious and boring
these depraved attention mongers can't
even manage to be offensive in an
interesting way
instead they simply recycle the same
shock tactics over and over again
and we've seen it all by now
as it turns out there are only so many
ways to be a satanic after a while
it gets repetitive and and we are way
past that point today
but with that said even if these
degenerate pop stars are just vying for
our attention in the most obvious
overdone ways because they have the IQ
and creative Talent of a paper plate
there's still a certain significance to
the fact that a major broadcast network
uh you know broadcast a Satanic ritual
live on air last night
I think it'd be a mistake to ignore this
development completely instead we should
I think focus on it for long enough to
learn the lesson that this event can
teach us two lessons really
first
the left's cultural agenda is to tear
down and desecrate all that you love and
hold as sacred they have no ideas of
their own they have no plan beyond the
the destruction
that's why they borrow from Christianity
even while they try to ridicule it they
have to in effect sit on the same limb
they're trying to saw off the tree they
can't stand on their own they have
nothing they don't have their own
platform
it's an agenda motivated by pure hatred
and resentment they don't even know why
they hate what they hate but they do
hate it and their hatred drives them to
destroy
second and I think maybe most important
point
is that leftism is satanism
there's a reason they rely so heavily on
satanic imagery and all that kind of
stuff they are all literally satanists
just not for the most part theological
sadness
that's an important distinction here
there are some theological sadness out
there who actually worship the devil
outwardly you know
um but these people they don't consider
themselves and most leftists they
certainly don't consider themselves to
be worshiping a being called Satan
rather they're worshiping what Satan
worshiped which is the self
the story of Satan is that he refused to
worship and serve God choosing instead
to worship and serve himself and the
modern leftist has made the same choice
leftism is the worship of the self
it is the elevation of the self
and the wants and desires of the self
especially the sexual wants and desires
above everyone and everything else
almost all modern pop music is an Ode to
this idea pop stars are
singing praises to the gospel of
self-worship which is to say that most
of it is satanic
yes there's something that Media Matters
can pull most pop music is satanic
because it is it is is about promoting
the worship of the self
it's just that it's usually not so
explicit about it
but I think it's probably better that
they are explicit
so that people can see all this stuff
for what it really is
and respond accordingly to it
and that'll do it for this portion the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]